devant les députés vous en avez marre de
vidéos plus mathieu les unes que les
autres vous voulez un petit peu de
gamineries de choses moins sérieuses et
bah ça tombe bien parce qu'aujourd'hui
on est sur mu 10 à 8 2 c'est un jeu qui
traite de kaka j'ai honte de le dire je
le dis très vite de ces parties planes
aux caisses et l'intro à que monter une
chaîne en quelques as n'a aucun sens ok
c'est parti quel est le but de ce [ __ ]
de jeu gold ben voilà il faut chauffer 3
rouleaux de pq faire un combo de disent
avoir un score de 20 milles au saas est
mal crottes ça ok on peut glisser
maintenant bien c'est génial attaque
mais que ça quand elle est invincible
quoi il a mangé dickens et avance même
possible mais on a fait le combo on est
bon on retourne du coup on a eu de
l'argent normalement on va pouvoir
pimp et voilà on a eu un dollar mois par
pimpé dont kkr exemple avoir à double
sommet qu olala c'est bien lancée alors
eux sur les rouleaux de pq mec ça c'est
la vraie question où est le pq ça non
c'est faux ce pas ça aux capteurs sur
les toits coach comme le croit car une
option possible alors on va essayer de
ruiner les cinq dîners au quai d'honneur
2,3 et 2,4 et on en plus cela fait le
score de 20 mille atom est qu il est
trop fort il manque les deux rouleaux de
pq mais c'est génial tu les trouves à
ben de faire tourner ton caca
jean-michel là faut attendre mon avis
c'est vers là bas mais que ça doit être
super loin pq ou est super qu aux mecs
jetez surtout s'ils sont tellement fou
rhodia pour faire un jeu sur le caca ils
sont complètement malade
oui peut être le dernier rouleau de pq
mec j'avais chez j'avais chez
[Musique]
oui les saultois là mais j'avais raison
comment tu fais attention tu en es tu
verras le petit balcon qui attend non ok
boum ça c'est fait non le mieux c'est
d'aller là bas même rôle avec tout con
allons finir en beauté monster qu'il a
sa part sur une piscine [ __ ] c'est le
mandat il doit cheminer entre georges
fenech maman et tout le monde était au
tour n'a pu signer personne dedans du
coup j'étais content elle était là pour
moi tout seul j'ai sauté dedans vous à
une bombe j'étais super heureux
sauf qu'en fait si tout le monde était
au top parce qu'un petit venait de faire
khak et a deux dents du coup on va se
manger alors c'est pareil 3 ou le papier
fait un combo de 15 40 mille score et
être un dj wahaha attendait regarder on
m'a tout de suite allé sur moi en ce
jour terrible voilà
sauver la sauver l'autre à tutoyer il
est vraiment mort mon gars bah ça c'est
moi quand j'ai appris qu'avec kaka dans
la piscine one x à leon neal dj dj cac
est dans la place
dj maturité aussi saoulé petula make
désolé up la masse et jusqu'à quand tu
bronzage je glisse sur le sable c'est ma
vie aujourd'hui en tant que kaka pour
m'écraser finalement comme ce poteau
[Musique]
le silencieux on connaît bien je suis
sur la retrouver regardez bien oui là où
la chaise maître nageur brian wahlberg
est ce qu'on peut monter cette échelle
en tant que kaka allait monter chez elle
au québec alors là on a fait une belle
jingle bell monter cette échelle c'est
parti mais comment tu veux faire plus
tard mais c'est sérieux
allez on y va on y va on y va ce parti
ce parti ce parti pas de temps à perdre
pas tant pour les lots et ce cap en
glace à qu'est ce qu'il fout là il y en
a plein le dos en attendant on va les
voir n'est pas une vie trop quoi pour
rentrer les tht dégueulasse et aux
camions bâtard plus perso droit
d'acheter les classes à mes génies des
mecs j'ai eu des jets d eau qu est ce
pas mr ans le vieux os merde on va
tâcher ses marchés ensuite on va les
attendre la petite fête qu'ils font là
bas ils vont prendre paniquent et ils
vont tous tombés comme des merdes
regardez bien voilà regardez c'est parti
attention vont tous glisse et ça a
marché avec là ça marche ça marche ça
marche
oui yes le combo de cars bon maintenant
il faut qu'on trouve les pq mais qu'ai
je me suis double jeu pour bâle
atteindre la mer n'est rien et puis ils
ont s'envolerait on s'appuie centraide
québec
mais c'est ça la technique en fait aulas
c'est l'os
oh
le premier cacao - dalet sur une chaise
de maître nageur à un gamin de nageurs
se soulagent un jour mais que c'est
abusé quand il a caché le pq le ghana il
fait ça
[Musique]
ok plus qu'à la gare où un mec aurait pu
cacher sa non j'aurais placé d'enduro
[Musique]
mais tu en voilà je me tire sur mon
voilier on s'appelle c'est l'heure du
parc d'attractions sympa ça n'est pas un
truc vert là et pas un truc vert là
c'est pas là pour rien ça ne mentez pas
et voilà il ya un pq
il faut faire dérailler le train
pourquoi il n'a pas déraillé
la lra est un voyage fantastique et la
rambarde oui mais ils vont mourir
oh je suis désolé ok on peut atteindre
le pq mais qu on y croit
saab on dit ça mais non ça bon dit ça
j'ai eu des james bond super ça peut
avoir sur leurs gardes et c'est faux
mais ça mais ça à sketches plus tard via
l'api d'après mes calculs on est bons
experts fécale qui suit affaires et
l'oiseau l'oiseau l'oiseau loiseau oh là
là là [ __ ] ce sniper fécales
c'est abusé oh oui d'un épais tu es un
mec c'est sûr il est où là où on
s'attache bien ça nous a menés tout
droit là où mon gars yes yes c'est
palpitant ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
ok nous reste un papier toilette un
combo de vingt et un score de 60 milles
c'est parti en fait il ya trois ans très
différent du coup il faut salir le sol
de toiles entrée 10
aller glisser glisser ces partis au
regard des combos oui merci à tous pour
votre participation in an explique ainsi
qu à trouver maintenant on n'est pas sur
un oiseau kohn a maintenant je coule sur
le toit des chemins réussi à l'avoir
tout à l'heure c'est sur cette superbe
action que cette vidéo on a de bonnes
mouettes [ __ ] aussi attendait pas on
est étourdi par cette action ben je
viens d'avoir le papier toilette
je venais de fêter ça comme il se doit
sauf que la capture s'est arrêté juste
avant à prendre comme il est roi où le
pq fait un combo de 20 et 60 mines au
score ouais j'en suis a pâti des eaux
sur medi and the spasm la puce et cas
n'hésitez pas bref d'eau que d'habitude
si vous voulez d'autres vidéos un peu
moins en matière d'habitudes comme celle
ci à bavans n'hésitez pas c'est vrai
qu'elles sont très rares sur la chaîne
en ainsi sur seul blague perçoit rien
dans ce traité sa prochaine vidéo portez
vous bien tout en glisse
[Musique]
ans